THIS IS NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT NOTICESTHE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHEN CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA MIKE LONG VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON HAITI HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LIII LEVINE. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN MURATSUCHI THIS
AREA WHEN O'DONNELL SEND
PETRIE-NORRIS QUOTE QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH STONE
TAKING FELLOW THERE AS BE
APPROVED RAW VOEPEL WALDRON WARD
WEBER RICK'S WILSON WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. THE
REQUIREMENTS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK THAT ARE.
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER. WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN
THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
MAYBE JOIN IN PRAYER PLEASE ALL
THE WORK. OUR LORD HOW MAJESTIC
IS YOUR NAME. WE PAUSE AT THIS
MOMENT TO TURN OUR HEARTS AND
MINDS TOWARD YOU. GOD YOU HAVE
CALLED EACH OF THESE FINE MEN
AND WOMEN TO THEIR RESPECTIVE
POSITIONS IN THIS GREAT CHAMBER
TO SERVE YOU. TO SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS. TO SERVE EACH
DISTRICT OF OUR GREAT STATE.
GRANT EACH OF THEM WITH THEM AS
THEY SEEK TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
BOTH RIGHT AND NECESSARY FOR
CALIFORNIA AT THIS TIME. MAY YOU
CONTINUE TO BLESS THIS GREAT
STATE OF OURS. THROUGH THE
FAITHFUL SERVICE OF EACH MEMBER
OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY I MEAN. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
LACKEY. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THIS
PRIVILEGE. DILIGENCE TO THE FAR
. SO. WHICH STANDS. YOU KNOW
THERE IS A STRONG. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY
GERMAN SACRAMENTO THURSDAY APRIL
TWENTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TO
THE ASSEMBLY BENNETT NINETY ON
THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEMPORE IF YOU SIMPLY
PRESIDING TO FOLKS WHO PARK AT
THE DESK PARTICULAR DAVID BOWMAN
READING WILL CALL THE ROLL WAS
CALLED TACKLE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDING MOVE CORE CALL
THE ASSEMBLY BUSHMILLS REYES
MOVES SAID MR FLORA. SECONDS THE
READING OF A- DAY'S JOURNAL WILL
BE DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
EMITATIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ. AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR. THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. HUVANE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
N. MS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY THEY HAVE
A GUEST ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM NINETEEN. EIGHTY
SIXTEEN NINETY THREE OF US TO
THE INACTIVE FILE. THE CLERK
WILL NOTE I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO ORDER S. B. EIGHT
NINE EIGHT DODD THAT TO THE
SECOND READING FILE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME. SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY. MEMBERS BY CAN HAVE
EXTENSION. PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE REAR THE
CHAMBER TO MIKE TO ASK MR
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM
MY DESK. AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER IT'S WITH GREAT
PLEASURE THAT WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO RECOGNIZE A CHAMPION FOR OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS AND FRANKLY
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA- CAMILLE
MAY BEEN RECENTLY RETIRED FROM
LEADING THE CALIFORNIA FIRST
FIVE COMMISSION. BUT BEFORE THAT
SHE'S HAD MANY DECADES OF
ADVOCACY AND WORK ON BEHALF OF
OUR KIDS AND STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- FOCUSING THE LAST
DECADE OR SO ON OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS- SHE ALSO SERVED AS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER LIKE MANY OF
US HERE PUTTING YOUR NAME ON THE
BALLOTS ARE ALL OF US OF COURSE
PER NAME ON THE BALLOT. SHE
BEGAN HERE IN THIS HOUSE SERVING
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER DELAINE
EASTIN- THEN TRANSITIONING OVER
TO HER EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. SERVING
FOR A COUPLE A STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION THEN TRANSITIONING
OVER AS I MENTIONED TO THE
CALIFORNIA FIRST FIVE COMMISSION
WHERE SHE'S WORKED TO MAKE SURE
WE EXPAND ACCESS TO OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS SO PLEASE JOIN ME. IN
WISHING A HEALTHY AND ACTIVE
RETIREMENT TO CAMILLE MAVEN
THANK YOU.
AND OF COURSE WE WANTED
KNOWLEDGE FOR FAMILY AND FRIENDS
UP IN THE GALLERY THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO THE- BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
TWELVE TWENTY TWO OR NINE
INNOCENT PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE
NINETEEN. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE AHEAD. IN THE FILE
. TO ALLOW MR RODRIGUEZ TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. ONE ZERO NINE ACR. ONE SEVENTY FIVE. FILE ITEM
ONE OR NINE ACR ONE SEVENTY FIVE.
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES WEEK
MR RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR ACR
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PROCLAIMS MAY
FIFTEENTH THROUGH MAY TWENTY
FIRST AS EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES WEEK IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS YEAR'S THEME IS RISING TO
THE CHALLENGE YOU MUST WEEK IS
AN ANNUAL OCCURRENCE TO
RECOGNIZE AND HONOR THE VALUE
AND DEDICATION OF THESE
PROFESSIONALS WHO PROVIDE
LIFESAVING CARE AND TREATMENT TO
THOSE IN THEIR TIME OF NEED.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICE PERSONNEL WHO
TREAT MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS A
YEAR. EMS PERSONNEL HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT SACRIFICES DURING
THE COURSE OF THEIR DUTY WHICH
INCLUDES PLACING THEIR OWN LIVES
ON THE LINE AS WELL AS MISSING
SPECIAL MOMENTS WITH THE OWN
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS IN ORDER TO
SAVE OURS. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I
WAS A FIRST RESPONDER FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS AND I CAN ATTEST TO
THE TRUE PROFESSIONALISM AND
PASSION THESE INDIVIDUALS BRING
TO THEIR WORK. DUE TO THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OUR EMS
PERSONNEL HAD TO FACE AN EVEN
BIGGER CHALLENGE BUT THE
RESPONSE WAS REMARKABLE. THESE
PROFESSIONALS PLACE THEIR OWN
SAFETY ON THE LINE RESPOND TO
TRAGEDIES SUCH AS THE RECENT
SACRAMENTO MASS SHOOTING AND THE
SHOOTING OVER THIS PAST WEEKEND
AT A CHURCH IN ORANGE COUNTY. I
KNOW WE'RE ALL PRAYING FOR THOSE
INVOLVED IN THIS TRAGEDY AS WELL
AS THE ONE WE HAD IN NEW YORK.
AND JUST WEEKS AGO A LOS SOUNDED
A CHPOFFICER USED HIS OWN
PATROL VEHICLE TO COLLIDE WITH
AND STOP A- HIGH SPEED ONE WAY
DRIVER. IN ADDITION TO THE
PHYSICAL DANGER FACING EMERGENCY
MEDICAL PERSONNEL. THIS
WORKFORCE FACES ONE OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF OCCURRENCE OF
MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESS. PAIRED
WITH THE LOWEST LIKELIHOOD OF
SEEKING TREATMENT. MANY OF THEIR
LIVES HAVE BEEN LOST BUT THEIR
SACRIFICE AND BRAVERY WILL NEVER
BE FORGOTTEN. THIS RESOLUTION
COMMENDS ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS. FOR THE SELFLESSNESS
SACRIFICES AND DEDICATION. ON
YOUR DOZEN MEMBERS YOU'LL FIND
EMS OF HELP IN MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME AND WEARING THIS WEARING
IT THIS WEEK AND HONOR OUR EMS
PERSONNEL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR OUR VOTE THE REQUESTED THE
FIRST ROW BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
RODRIGUEZ MISTER SEYARTO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
I STAND AS AN HONOR JOIN AUTHOR
AND IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
SEVENTY FIVE FIRST I WOULD THEY
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
HIS TREMENDOUS WORK NOT JUST
HONORING BUT ALSO REPRESENTING
THE COURAGEOUS INDIVIDUALS AND
HARD WORKING INDIVIDUALS OF OUR
EMS COMMUNITY. ARE UNIQUELY
UNDERSTAND THE DEMANDS PLACED ON
THESE UNSUNG HEROES HAVING
STARTED AS A PARAMEDIC IN THE
FIRE SERVICE OVER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO. WORKING VERY LONG
HOURS AND SOMETIMES DAYS ON END
AND WITNESSING SOME OF THE MOST
TRYING MOMENTS IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
TAKES A TOLL. OUR COMMUNITY OF
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE
PERSONNEL ARE DESERVING OF OUR
THANKS AND RESPECT IT IS FOR
THAT ROOM THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK MISS SEYARTO.
SAY NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MISTER RODRIGUEZ'S
ASSET THE FIRST ROLL BE OVER FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. CALL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHOR SUNNY C. R. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLE THEIR SIXTY
THREE SIXTY FOUR CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY YES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ WE
WELCOME STAFF MEMBERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
SACRAMENTO FIRE IN A. M. R. WHO
ARE SEATED IN THE GALLERY.
WELCOME.
AND MEMBERS MOVING BRIEFLY BACK.
TO GUEST INTRODUCTIONS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL GUESTS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY. WE WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME GUESTS IN THE GALLERY
FROM PARENT VOICES OF OAKLAND
AND INGLEWOOD AND THAT'S ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
WELCOME.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
THE TOP OF THE FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION ITEM FOR SHALL
BE CONTINUED ON THE ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEMS
FIVE. THROUGH THIRTEEN PASS AND
RETAIN THAT BRINGS US TO MISS
CERVANTES THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB. TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
SIX AND THE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES. THE
PURPOSE OF AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
SIX IS TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
LGBTQ FAMILIES WISHING TO SERVE
AS A RESOURCE FAMILY FOR FOSTER
CHILDREN AND TO REMOVE THE
STATUTORY STIGMA ATTACHED TO THE
LGBTQ FOSTER CHILDREN THANKS TO
SIGNIFICANT REFORMS APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE RECENT YEARS
MORE MORE LGBTQ FAMILIES ARE
SEEKING TO OFFER THEIR SERVICES
AS RESOURCE FAMILIES WHICH
PROVIDES OUT OF HOME CARE FOR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE. AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SIX WILL
PROVIDE NEEDED PROTECTIONS BY
PROHIBITING PLACING AGENCIES
FROM DECLINING TO PLACE OUR
FOSTER CHILD WITH THE RESOURCE
FAMILY SOLELY ON THE GROUNDS
THAT THE RESOURCE FAMILY
IDENTIFIES AS LGBTQ THIS BILL
WILL ADDITIONALLY AND STATUTORY
STIGMATA BY REMOVING THE TERM
HARD TO PLACE CHILDREN FROM OUR
STATE LAWS UNFORTUNATELY MANY
LGBT Q. U. CONTINUE TO REPORT
DISCRIMINATION MARGINALIZATION
AND OVERALL LOCKED OF THIS OF
ACCEPTANCE WHEN NAVIGATING OUR
STATE'S CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
THIS WHOLLY UNFAIR
CLASSIFICATION ON THE BASIS OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION ALONE CAN
HINDER FOSTER PLACEMENT AND
UNNECESSARILY INFLICT TRAUMA
UNDER LGBTQ FOSTER CHILDREN WE
MUST STRIVE TO INSTILL THIS
BASIC PRINCIPLE IN OUR FOSTER
CARESYSTEM BECAUSE NO CHILD IS
TOO DIFFICULT TO LOVE OR CARE
FOR. JUST BECAUSE THEIR RACE
RELIGION DISABILITY OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION UNTIL CONGRESS
PASSES A NATION WIDE LAWS
PROHIBITING DISCRIMINATION ON
THE BASIS OF SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OR GENDER IDENTITY STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA MY STEP UP PROTECT
EMBRACE AND EMPOWERLGBTQ
COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER S.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLERK LOVE THE ROLE
. SARAH VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT IS FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN. PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS SEVENTEEN THROUGH
NINETEEN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY. THIS IS AB SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT BY MISTER GIPSON CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
AWAIT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
AND OTHERS AND I PUTTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MISTER GIBSON EMAIL
BUT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL ON SIXTEEN OH EIGHT WHICH
SEEKS TO SEPARATE CORNERS
OFFICE. FROM SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND COUNTIES SUCH
ACROSS THE STATE CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY ONE OF ONLY THREE
STATES THAT STILL ALLOW COUNTIES
TO COMBINE THE OFFICE OF THE
CORNERS AND THE SHARES. FOR
YEARS WE HAVE WITNESSED FAR TOO
MANY TRAGEDIES. PATTERNS OF
INCONSISTENCIES BECAUSE SHARES
ARE ALLOWED TO OVERSEE THE CAUSE
OF DEATH RULINGS. THIS HAS
RESULTED IN BIAS MEDICAL
INVESTIGATION TIME AND TIME
AGAIN ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT WE'LL PUT CALIFORNIA IN
LINE WITH THE REST OF THE
STATES. THAT HAVE ALREADY
ADVANCED A SIMILAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION LIKE ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN OH EIGHT IN CALIFORNIA
TEN COUNTIES ALREADY ARE DOING
WHAT A. B. SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
SEEKS TO ACCOMPLISH. HERE TODAY
IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR ANGELO
CANTIL A UNITED STATES NAVY
VETERAN FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED BY POLICE
. ANGELO KATO'S CASE EIGHT
MONTHS AFTER THE DEATH THE CAR
COSTA COUNTY CORONER'S OFFICE
ISSUED A REPORT AFTER THE
AUTOPSY AND THE RULING WAS THAT
DEATH WAS AN ACCIDENT AND LISTED
THE CAUSE OF DEATH UNDERSCORE
THIS. EXCITED DELIRIUM THE TERM
EXCITED DELIRIUM IS REJECTED
COLLEAGUES BY THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION AND THE
AMERICAN- PEDIATRICS OR ON SKEWS
ME PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION THIS
TERM HAS BEEN REJECTED TIME AND
TIME AGAIN BY THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY YET IT IS STILL USED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO EXPLAIN ON
CERTAIN DEATHS OCCURRING IN WITH
AND WITH POLICE CUSTODY CURRENT
LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE A SHERIFF'S
TO HAVE ANY MEDICAL BACKGROUND
OR CERTIFICATION TO ASSUME THE
DUTIES OF A CORNERS AS A RESULT.
IT HAS CAUSED MANY QUESTIONS
WHETHER A MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS IS
BALLOT WIN WIN THERE IS AN
OFFICER INVOLVED DEATH MEMBERS
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE
ON ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON
MS BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MEMBERS AND MISTER SPEAKER I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTES ON AB
SIXTEEN OH EIGHT I HAVE HELD IN
MY ARMS THE MOTHER OF ANGELA
TELL HER THIS. AT TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT SHE DREADS THAT SHE
EVER MADE THE CALL TO SEEK
SUPPORT FOR HER BROTHER. AND
WITH THAT WE KNOW THAT WE WHEN
WE WANT THE BEST AND THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY. OF OUR
PUBLIC SERVANTS WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT OUR OFFICERS
ARE SHERIFFS ARE SEPARATED FROM
THE DECISIONS THAT THE CORNER
MAKES. SO IT IS INCREDIBLY
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE A
SEPARATION IF YOU WILL FROM THE
CORNER AND THE SHERIFF'S AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
BONTA DR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE AS A PROUD JOINT
CO AUTHOR OF AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
. FOR YEARS WE HAVE WITNESSED
FAR TOO MANY TRAGEDIES AND
PATTERNS OF AN INCONSISTENCY
BECAUSE SHERIFFS ARE ALLOWED TO
OVERSEE THE CAUSE OF DEATH
RULINGS. UNFORTUNATELY OUT OF
STATE IF THIS HAPPENED TO THE
FAMILY OF ANGELO QUINTO WHO I
MET WAS SHORTLY AFTER THE POLICE
TRAGICALLY KILLED THEIR SON. IT
TOOK OVER SEVEN MONTHS AFTER HIS
DEATH. BUT THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTER. CORNER TO ISSUE A
REPORT SEVEN MONTHS. AND THAT'S
WAS STATED THE REPORT WHICH
RULED HIS DEATH AN ACCIDENT AND
LISTED THE CAUSE OF DEATH AS
EXCITED DELIRIUM. NOT A
PHYSICIAN I HAVE NEVER HEARD
THIS AS A MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS AND
SO I HAD TO DO MY OWN RESEARCH
ON WHAT EXACTLY IS THIS EXCITED
DELIRIUM. AND YES IT IS A TERM
THAT HAS BEEN REJECTED BY THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY. AND AS I WAS
REVIEWING SCIENTIFIC REVIEWS IT
HAS SHOWN THAT EXCITED DELIRIUM
IS MOST OFTEN THE RESULT OF
POLICE AGGRESSIVE FORMS OF
POLICE RESTRAINT. THAT'S WHEN IF
YOU. AND SO IF WE SEPARATE THE
CORONER'S OFFICE FROM THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE IT CREATES
TRANSPARENCY NOT ONLY FOR THIS
FAMILY BUT FOR MANY FAMILIES WHO
HAVE HAD TO INDOOR THIS KIND OF
TRAGEDY. WE WILL NOT HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT OUTSIDE INFLUENCES.
AND IT ULTIMATELYGIVES THE
FAMILIES THE PEACE WHEN THEIR
LOVED ONE HAS PASSED AWAY. AND
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
pMISTER CAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE-
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT. AS ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY WHO REPRESENTS CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT I ADD ON TO WHAT
YOU HEARD MARK CALLING FROM SAN
DIEGO. WHICH IS NOT ONLY WERE
THERE QUESTIONS BEING POSED BY A
COLLEAGUE OF OURS WHO'S A
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL BUT THE
COMMUNITY THAT I REPRESENT
DOESN'T HAVE FAITH IN THE
OUTCOMES OF THESE AUTOPSIES. AND
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF IS REASON
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US SHOULD WANT OUR
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE FAITH IN THE
PROCESS SEIZE ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE WHO LOST A LOVED ONE. AND
WHEN I HEAR FROM MY OWN
COMMUNITY THAT THEY DON'T
BELIEVE WHAT COMES OUT OF THAT
OFFICE BECAUSE OF THE INHERENT
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WE HAVE A
REAL PROBLEM. AND SO WE NEED TO
CORRECT THIS AND ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE PROCESSES THAT ARE SEPARATE
TRUSTWORTHY AND GIVE OUR
COMMUNITY A BELIEF THAT OUR
PROCESS EASIER JUST AND EVERYONE
IS GETTING THE OUTCOME THAT THEY
DESERVE AND THAT IS NOT WHAT IS
HAPPENING TODAY. AND OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM LA'S BILL WILL
CHANGE THAT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR EVERYBODY'S SUPPORT.
THANK MISS AMERICA. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. MISTER GIBSON YOU
MAY CLOSE WE WISH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I DON'T THINK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR LENDING THEIR VOICES IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT AGAIN THIS BILL IS
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- LOS ANGELES
COUNTY- HAD A SYSTEM IN WHICH
THE SHERIFF'S OVERSAW THE
CORONER'S OFFICE THEY SEPARATED
SO IT SAN FRANCISCO SO THAT SAN
DIEGO AND MANY OTHER- COUNTIES
HAVE TAKEN SIMILAR STEPS. AGAIN
AS THE ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT WILL PROVIDE FAMILIES WITH
THE PEACE OF MIND THAT THE CAUSE
OF DEATH INVESTIGATIONS PROCESS
ARE DONE RIGHTEOUSLY AND FAIRLY
AGAIN THIS BILL IS ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
I RESPECTFULLY WHEN I VOTE ON
ASSEMBLY BILL. SIXTEEN OH EIGHT.
AND WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GONNA PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS TWENTY ONE.
THROUGH. TWENTY NINE. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM THIRTY.
AB TWO THOUSAND BY MR GABRIEL
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO THOUSAND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL EVOLUTIONARILY VEHICLE
MISTER GABRIEL YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES TODAY RISE 2% AB TWO
THOUSAND WHICH WILL CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE IN LAW REGARDING STREET
RACING AND **** SIDESHOWS IN
PARKING LOTS. OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL HAS REPORTED A NEARLY
3100% SURGE IN EXHIBITION OF
SPEED SUBSIDE PATIENTS.
APPROXIMATELY 11% OF THESE
CRASHES ASSOCIATE WITH
EXHIBITIONS OF SPEED HAVE
RESULTED IN DEATH. STREET RACING
AND TRIED SUICIDE DEVASTATE
FAMILIES HARM INNOCENT
BYSTANDERS AND CREATE SERIOUS
RISKS FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE I
KNOW THAT THIS IS PARTICULARLY
TRUE WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF VERY
UNFORTUNATE INCIDENTS IN MY
COMMUNITY. IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY WHERE STREET RACING
KELCE. AB TWO THOUSAND MODESTLY
EXPANDS CURRENT LAW REGARDING
EXHIBITION OF SPEED AND SPEED
CONTEST TO INCLUDE PARKING LOTS.
WHICH WILL HELP TO CRACK DOWN ON
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES AND SAVE
LIVES THIS MEASURE HELP PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITY AND SAVE THE LIVES
OF YOUNG PEOPLE AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL MR FONG
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I THINK IT
WAS A SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THOUSAND AND
I'M VERY GRATEFUL FR THE
DEDICATION OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY TO
KEEPING OUR ROADS DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS SAFE. EVERY SINGLE
WEEKEND THERE ARE STORIES ABOUT
ILLEGAL STREET RACES AND
DANGEROUS SIDE SHOWS SHUTTING
DOWN OUR STREETS CAUSING
ACCIDENTS. AND HARMING OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS THERE
UNPREDICTABLE DEVASTATING AND
WHEN THEY GET VIOLENT THEY
BECAUSE CENSUS DEBTS THAT
DESTROY FAMILIES. THE STORIES
I'VE HEARD FROM MY CONSTITUENTS
IN OTHER FAMILIES THAT SUFFERED
LOSSES FROM SIDE SHOWS ARE
TRAGIC. THESE FAMILIES HAVE
TURNED THEIR PAIN INTO STRONG
ADVOCACY TO COMBAT THIS
DANGEROUS ACTIVITY. THIS BILL IS
AN IMPORTANT NEXT STEP IN
CRACKING DOWN ON ILLEGAL
SIDESHOWS SIDE'S SIDE SHOWS A
MOVE FROM PARKING LOTS. TO OUR
STREETS WHERE THEY'RE EQUALLY
DANGEROUS AND NEED TO BE STOPPED
MEMBERS I'D STRONGLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK IMAGE PHARMACY SAY
ARE TELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY OUT STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THOUSAND AND
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR- THIS IS A VERY
THOUGHTFUL MEASURE. AND IT'S
VERY TIMELY- THE ISSUES STREET
RACING AND- PARKING LOT STUNTS
IS BECOMING SOMETHING THAT
AFFECTS EVERY COMMUNITY ACROSS
THE STATE. WE SEE IT SOMETIMES
FIRST HAND WE SEE IN THE PAPERS
BYSTANDERS ARE BEING STRUCK AND
KILLED. AB TWO THOUSAND WILL
HELP OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT GIVEN
THE TOOLS TO PROTECT THE KERR OF
THE PUBLIC AND CURB THE IMPACTS
THAT THESE PARKING LOT STREET
RACERS HAVE ON OUR COMMUNITY IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THE FAMOUS.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MR GABRIEL YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES. THIS MEASURE
BUILT ON A BIPARTISAN BILL THAT
MR FONG MISTREATMENT MISTER
NAZARIAN I DID LAST YEAR. AND I
THINK THE ONE THING THAT WE ALL
HAVE IN COMMON IS THAT ALL OF US
HAVE HAD TO MEET WITH THE
PARENTS. WHO HAVE BEEN PEOPLE
KILLED IN THESE TRAGIC ACCIDENTS
IT'S ON BEHALF OF THEM WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TWO THOUSAND. AND WITH
THAT CAR CLUB ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS THIRTY ONE
. THROUGH. THIRTY EIGHT. THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE. AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY QUINN AND OTHERS THAT
PUTTING THE OIL SPILLS MISSED
WHEN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
ON OCTOBER FIRST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE AND OILS RELATED
INCIDENT A CURRENT ORANGE COUNTY
THE RESULT IN TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND GALLONS OF CRUDE OIL
LEAKING INTO THE OCEAN IN MY
DISTRICT THE SOURCE OF THE OIL
IT WAS LATER DETERMINED TO BE A
PIPELINE WITH A THIRTEEN INCH
CRACK. INVESTIGATORS BELIEVE
THAT THE DAMAGE  PIPE I WAS
MOST LIKELY CAUSED BY PASSING
SHIPS ANCHOR WHICH DISPLAYS THE
PIPE BY OVER ONE HUNDRED FEET A
MAY HAVE OCCURRED MONTHS TO A
YEAR PRIOR TO THE INCIDENT.
DESPITE THIS ON. SERIES OF
EVENTS AN INVESTIGATION TO
INCIDENT ALSO FOUND THE DAMAGED
PIPELINE IT RESULTING. WEEK WAS
NOT PROPERLY REPORTED POTENTIAL
DELAYED A RESPONSE FROM STATE
AND FEDERAL AUTHORITIES THEY
COULD HAVE PREVENTED. THE
INCIDENT FROM LEAKING FOR THE
INTO THE OCEAN ON A TO OUR
BEACHES. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES BE NOTIFIED
IMMEDIATELY. OF ANY OIL SPILL
THAT AFFECTS STATE AND FEDERAL
LAWS. THE FEDERAL WATERS BIZ
EXPANDS EXISTING NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND CAN HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND AGENCIES RESPOND.
IN A TIMELY AND EFFICIENT MANNER
IN THE INCIDENT. THIS BILL HAS
THE ENJOY BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISSED ONE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CARCLUB THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE. TELL YOU
WHAT I SIXTY THREE DOES ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS. FORTY ONE. THROUGH FORTY SIX
PASS AND RETAIN.
MY APOLOGIES MISS WHEN WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM FORTY
THIS IS FORTY AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL%
SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN AND OTHERS
MACALINTAL OIL SPILLS MISSED ONE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
AGAIN TO PRESENT- AB SIXTY FIFTY
EIGHT ON A SIMILAR ISSUE IT
SIMILAR INCIDENT THAT I'VE-
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED. IT IS VERY
CLEAR THOUGH THAT DURING THIS
TIME IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
DIFFERENT BEACHES CITY A BEACH
CITIES COUNTY STATE AND FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES HAD NO PLANS OR
DIFFERENT PLANS ON HOW TO
RESPOND TO AN OIL SPILL. MY BILL
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT WOULD
ENCOURAGE LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
DEVELOP AN OIL SPILL RESPONSE
PLAN THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
BOTH THE STATE AND FEDERAL LAW.
FEDERAL OIL SPILL CONTINGENCY
PLANS WHEN A SYSTEM THROUGH A
GRANT PROGRAM COASTAL CITIES
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO RESOURCES
TO HELP THEM PLAN BE PREPARED IN
CASE OF AN INCIDENT AND HAVE
SIMILAR EFFORTS. IN PLACE TO
RESPOND HAVING SUCH PLANS IN
PLACE WHEN RESPOND TO AN OIL
SPILL INCIDENT WILL HELP
COORDINATE EMERGENCY RESOURCES
AND DIRECTLY RESPOND TO THE-%
SITUATION A TIMER MANNER. AFTER
THE MEANS WE CAN BE A OUR BEST
WHEN THE CHAO. ARISES AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT HAS ALSO ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISSED ONE
. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
BECAUSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
TWO DOES ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. AN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN. WE'RE
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
THIRTY ONE. CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE AND OTHERS
NAPOLI THE MOBILE HOMES MR LEE
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY THIRTY
ONE WILL ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS
CAN BRING A REPRESENTATIVE TO
MEETINGS OF PARK MANAGEMENT TO
MAKE THESE MEETINGS MORE
IN THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION SPECTRALLY ASK DR A-
THANK YOU MISLI SEE NO
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CARPAL OF THE ROLE. OUT OF
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE. YEAH.
CLICK WELL. GET CLOSER ALL TIED
ABOUT HIGHS FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS TO
. THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY THREE CORPORATE
. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
THREE BY SUMMER WART ACT LIVING
. MR MORE YOU MAILED THANK YOU
MISTER STATE LAW REQUIRES LOCAL
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO FOLLOW
SPECIFIED PROCEDURES WHEN
CONTRACTING CERTAIN SERVICES THE
STATE'S REQUIRED TO SET AN
UPDATE THE PROCUREMENT THRESHOLD
LIMITS FOR EACH AGENCY WHICH
GOVERNOR WHAT PROCUREMENT METHOD
IS REQUIRED. UNFORTUNATELY FOR
THE SAN DIEGO METROPOLITAN
TRANSIT SYSTEM THE NORTH COUNTY
TRANSIT DISTRICT AND THE SAN
DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS
THE THRESHOLDS OF UP AND UPDATED
TO REFLECT THE INCREASED COST OF
GOODS AND NON CONSTRUCTION
SERVICES SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY THREE
UPDATES THE PROCUREMENT
THRESHOLDS FOR THE THREE STATE
AGENCIES TO MATCH THE CPI INDEX
INFLATION FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS WARD. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLICK LIBERAL. IT IS AT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF- CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ALL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS FORTY NINE AND FIFTY
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY NINE
CORPORATION SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD BACK IN TENNESSEE
THE SHOW MORE YOU MAY GET OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
YOUR DO THE CURRENT HOUSING
CRISIS RENTERS OFTEN HAVE TO
APPLY MULTIPLE PROPERTIES BEFORE
THE APPLICATION IS ACCEPTED IF A
RENTER APPLIES TO SEVERAL
PROPERTIES THE VARIOUS
APPLICATION FEES CAN QUICKLY ADD
UP TO SEVERAL HUNDRED DOLLARS.
TO ADDRESSES FINANCIAL BURIED
HOUSING THE STATE OF WASHINGTON
TO MARYLAND PASSED LEGISLATION
TO ALLOW LANDLORDS TO ACCEPT
REUSABLE SCREENING REPORTS THESE
REPORTS ARE GENERATED BY A THIRD
PARTY SCREENING REPORT PROVIDER
THAT WILL SECURELY GENERATE AND
SHARE A CERTIFIED SCREENING
REPORT WITH ANY PROSPECTIVE
LANDLORD AN APPLICANT AB TWO
FIVE FIVE NINE SINCE THE STATE
STANDARD FOR REUSABLE SCREEN
REPORTS TO BE USED DURING THE
RENTAL APPLICATION PROCESS IF
THE LANDLORD ALEXX TO ACCEPT
SUCH REPORTS BY USING A REUSABLE
SCREEN REPORT RENTERS ONLY HAVE
TO PAY A ONE TIME FOR THE
REPORT. THAT COULD BE USED MANY
TIMES OVER THIRTY DAY PERIOD C.
THEREBY SAVING THE RENTER MANY
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS WILL ALLOW
LANDLORDS TO EXPEDITIOUSLY
REVIEW VERIFIED APPLICANT
INFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIVAL ON. AB. TWO FIVE
FIVE NINE. THANK YOU MISTER WARD
ST NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. THE
CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSER ALL. TIE THE
ICE FORTY FIVE NO SEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE GOING TO
MISTER BERMAN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY TWO IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AB TWENTY
NINE TWELVE BY MISTER BERMAN AND
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY NINE TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AND I PUT IN THE
CONSUMER WARRANTIES MR BERMAN
EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY
NINE TWELVE WOULD REQUIRE
EXPRESS WARRANTIES TO START NO
EARLIER THAN THE DATE OF
DELIVERY RATHER THAN THE DATE OF
PURCHASE CURRENTLY WHEN AN
EXPRESS WARRANTY COMMENCES AT
THE TIME OF PURCHASE THE
CONSUMER DOES NOT RECEIVE THE
FULL BENEFIT OR DURATION OF THE
WARRANTY IF THE PRODUCT DOES NOT
RECEIVE THE SAME DAY. THIS WAS A
PROBLEM PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
BUT IT'S ONLY GROWN MORE
APPARENT WITH SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE IS
SUPPORTED BY NUMEROUS CONSUMER
ORGANIZATIONS MY OFFICE IS IN
COMMUNICATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AROUND IMPLEMENTATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MR BERMAN. SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
. WELL ABOVE THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIGN OF VOTE. CLARK WELL.
THE CLOSER ROLE TALLIED ABOUT I
SIXTY ONE KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE THROUGH FIFTY SEVEN. PASS
RETAIN MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX BY
MR GRAYSON. AND THE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AND
ACT LIVING APART PRODUCTS IN THE
CLARITY OF SIERRA PACIFIC ME.
MYSTERY EMAIL THANK YOU MISTRESS
AND- CURRENT LAW AUTHORIZES THE
BOARD OF PINE COMMISSIONERS TO
ADJUST AND CREATE SURCHARGES FOR
THE COST OF NEW PILOT BOATS.
THIS WAS A RESULT OF LAST YEAR'S
EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO SEVEN
AMAZINGLY IT MOVES THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS ON CONSENT
WITH UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX
WHICH IS THE BILL TODAY DOES ONE
THING IT'S SIMPLY AUTHORIZES THE
BOARD TO INCLUDE IN THE EXISTING
SURCHARGE THE COST OF UPGRADING
PILOT BOATS OR PURCHASING NEW
PILOT BOATS TO MEET EMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA. AIR RESOURCES BOARD
IT DOES NOT CREATE NEW FEES OR
SURCHARGES RECENTLY CARP HAS
PROPOSED REGULATIONS THAT WOULD
APPLY MORE STRINGENT
REQUIREMENTS TO IN USE AND NEW
VESSELS THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
CREATE DIFFICULT FINANCIAL
BURDENS. FOR THE STATE MANDATED
PILOTAGE INFRASTRUCTURE
COMPOUNDED WITH THE SERIOUS
CHALLENGES OF THE COVERT
PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT ON TO
SHIPPING TRADE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND SUPPLY CHAIN THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THE PILOT VESSELS ARE
ABLE TO MEET THE PROPOSED CARBON
ELECTIONS. WHILST CONTRIBUTING
TO THE STATE'S OVERALL EMISSION
REDUCTIONS GOALS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CLOSE CONSIDERATION OF THIS
MEASURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. IT IS
OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOSE. THIS TAKES FIFTY
FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
MISTER GRAYSON MOVES TO CALL.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SIX BY MISTER
GRAYSON AND THE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN
APPLET IN THE LAND USE MISTER
GRACE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SIX WILL
HELP MAKE CONNECTION CAPACITY
FEES MORE TRANSPARENT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS LEVY DEVELOPER
FEES TO PAY FOR THE SERVICES
NEEDED TO SUPPORT NEW HOUSING
AND TO OFFSET THE IMPACTS OF
GROWTH ON A COMMUNITY. THESE
FEES CAN MAKE UP A SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION OF THE COST TO BUILD NEW
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA AND
ALTHOUGH IMPACT FEES ARE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
GREATER CLARITY BETWEEN FEES AND
NEXUS STUDIES COULD HELP TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SIX WILL ESTABLISH
IMPORTANT NEW ACCOUNTABILITY
STANDARDS FOR THE STUDIES THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES USED TO CALCULATE
THE FEES THAT THEY IMPOSE ON NEW
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AS HAD
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK GOODNESS GRAYSON SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLERK LIBERAL. THAT REMOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE
. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS OUT OF
OUT. BURKE WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY NINE AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY EIGHT AGAIN THIS IS MISTER
GRAYSON CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX SIXTY EIGHT BY SOME
MEMBER GRAYSON IMMACULATE IN THE
HOUSING. THIS RACE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AGAIN I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY EIGHT WHICH WILL ALLOW
QUALIFIED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS TO EFFECTIVELY
STREAMLINE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
AS INTENDED UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE
MONUMENTAL EFFORTS TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON THE HOUSING CRISIS
HOWEVER. AMBIGUITIES IN THE LAW
HAVE EXPORTED TO DERAIL THAT IS
BADLY NEEDED HOUSING PROJECTS
ACROSS THE STATE AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY EIGHT SIMPLY CLARIFIES THE
LAW TO ENSURE IT FUNCTIONS AS
INTENDED IT HAS NO OPPOSITION OR
NO VOTES AND I DO RECOGNIZE
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR A VOTE.
THING GRAYSON SAME NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CARCLUB LAUREL. SORRY
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO DECIDE
ABOUT. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TYLER I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM SIXTY THROUGH SIXTY
TWO FOLLOW SIXTY THREE IS AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY FOUR AND THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE NINETY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY WARD
AND OTHER NOT PUTTING HIM MARCH
THE SHORT. THANK YOU WAS JUST A
BEACH ONE NINETY FORMER FORMER
AND PHARMACY TECHNICIANS TO HAVE
ONE HOUR OF CONTINUING EDUCATION
THAT PROVIDES CULTURALLY COME
CARE TO MEMBERS OF THE LGBT Q.
P. THIS WILL HELP. ADDRESS
HEALTH DISPARITIES FOR
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR EITHER. I THINK IT
WAS WORTH SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
- ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ZERO
CLARK WELL IT'S CLOSE ROLL TIDE
OF AN ICE FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR. AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY BY MR BERMAN
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY FIVE FORTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN ACKLINGTON DIRECT
DEPOSIT OF FUNDS. MR BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY FIVE THE AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY WILL ENSURE
THAT AN OPTION FOR FEE FREE
BANKING REMAINS AVAILABLE TO ALL
CONSUMERS. IT WOULD DO SO BY
CLARIFYING THAT ACCOUNTS THAT
OFFER VOLUNTARY TIPPING MAY ALSO
RECEIVE DIRECT DEPOSITS OF
PUBLIC FUNDS WHEN CONSUMER
SAFEGUARDS ARE MET. INCLUDING
CUSTOMERS MUST BE INFORMED THAT
ANY TIP IS OPTIONAL AND
REFUNDABLE THE CUSTOMER'S
ACCOUNT CANNOT BE ENHANCED OR
DIMINISHED BY THE DECISION TO
TIP OR NOT. IF THERE IS A
DEFAULT TIP AMOUNT THAT TIM OUT
MUST BE ZERO DOLLARS WE WORKED
WITH THE BANKING COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
FROM OPPONENTS TO PREVENT
PREDATORY PRACTICES AND MAINTAIN
OUR APPROPRIATELY HIGH CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH OPPONENTS ON
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS BERMAN
C. NOTICE KASHER DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. THE CLERK WILL YEAH YEAH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE TIDE
ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY THREE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL. ON FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
MISTER GRAY SINCE AB TWENTY
FIFTY SIX CORPORATE POST.
MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE. HOPEWELL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE EYES FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY AS FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE MEASURE THAT BILL
PASSES. BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE
ITEM SIXTY FIVE THROUGH SIXTY
EIGHT PASS. AND RETAIN THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE. HR ONE
AWAIT BY MISS IRWIN APPROPRIATE
HOUSE WAS SOLUTION ONE OH EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH.
MEASUREMENT THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT HR
ONE AWAIT WHICH RECOGNIZES MAY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. NATIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH
MENTAL ILLNESS TOUCHES MANY
CALIFORNIANS BUT MOST ALARMINGLY
AFFECTS OUR YOUTH A RECENT
REPORT BY THE U. S. SURGEON
GENERAL HAS SHOWN THAT SYMPTOMS
OF DEPRESSION AND AN ANXIETY
HAVE DOUBLED DURING THE PANDEMIC
WITH 25% OF YOUTH EXPERIENCING
SYMPTOMS OF DEPRESSION. JUST
THIS PAST OCTOBER THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
DECLARED A NATIONAL STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH. THIS THE NEED TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS BECOMES MORE
STRIKING WHEN WE CONSIDER MENTAL
ILLNESS IS MORE LIKELY TO IMPACT
LGBTQ YOUTH AND YOUTH OF COLOR
WE MUST PRIORITIZE INCREASING
ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH. AND WORK
TO CHANGE THE STIGMA AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT ON YOUR
DESKS YOU WILL SEE A LIME GREEN
RIBBON WHICH ARE WORN IN BRITAIN
AND THOSE ARE WARRANT TO BRING
AWARENESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
ILLNESS WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
WEAR YOUR RIBBON TODAY IN HONOR
OF NATIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH. THANK YOU TO
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT NAMI
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES FOR YOUR CO SPONSORSHIP
OF THIS RESOLUTION I ASSET THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MR
ONE. MR VOEPEL. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I SUPPORT THIS BILL
HR ONE AWAIT BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND THIS HOUSE THAT MENTAL
HEALTH FOR THE HOMELESS. IS
EXTREME AND MANY OF THE HOMELESS
HAVE BURNT OUR BRAINS OUT ON
DRUGS SO WE SHOULD ADDRESS THE
HOMELESS MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU. SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. MS OR ONE IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE THE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN. THIS
IS FOR MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK
WELL CLOSE RATHER SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. FILE ITEMS. SEVENTY
THROUGH. SEVENTY FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN. REGISTER FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY
THREE CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SEYARTO AND
OTHERS AND I PUT IN THE PUBLIC
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION MISTER
SEYARTO. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE SIXTEEN
THIRTY THREE IS AN INFORMATION
SHARING BILL BETWEEN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION WITH THIS BILL WE
CAN HELP CONNECT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF VETERANS ITH THEIR
WELL DESERVED BENEFITS. THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN CONSENT THROUGH
COMMITTEES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARCLUB THE ROLE. MEMBERS IS
THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT. TUCKWELL CLOSE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO BY
MYSTERY THIS AND THE CLERK WILL
BE SYMBOL SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
ACTIVATING THE CIGARETTES MAKE
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
MYSTERY VESTS I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- THIS LEGISLATION
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVEN FOUR TWO
SIX A STRAIGHT AND CLARIFY THE
EXISTING TOBACCO DIRECTLY
STATUTE. TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE MASTER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE MSA THIS
LEGISLATION WILL RESULT IN FIRST
ENSURING OUR STATE RECEIVES ALL
PAYMENTS OWED- BY SOME TOBACCO
MANUFACTURERS THROUGH THIS MSA
IN SECONDS IS LEGISLATION WILL
HELP REDUCE THE RISK OF A NON
FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES FROM
ENTERING THE MARKET PLACE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MISS RIVERS. SAY NOTICE.
DEBATE OUR CORPORATE. SORRY BOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OUT.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT
EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS TEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS RETAIN A
FOLLOW SEVEN THROUGH. EIGHTY
ONE. THE IS ITEM EIGHTY TWO AB.
EIGHT EIGHTY TWO. CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS AND OTHER NOT QUITE IN THE
HOSPITALS THIS RIVAS YOU MAY GET
OPEN ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE EIGHT EIGHT TO SIX TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY SO THAT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AGENCIES CAN
APPROPRIATELY PREPARE OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR A MAJOR SEISMIC
EVENT AND ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
IN THE CONTINUITY OF CRITICAL
CARE. FOR RESIDENTS YOU KNOW
EXISTING STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT
BY TWENTY THIRTY HOSPITAL
BUILDINGS TO BE DESIGNED OR
RETROFITTED AND CONSTRUCTED
REMAIN STANDING AFTER MAJOR
EARTHQUAKES AND ALSO BUT THEY
REMAIN CAPABLE OF PROVIDING
SERVICES IN CARE TO RESIDENTS.
AND CURRENTLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FIRST RESPONDERS THEY MAY NOT BE
AWARE OF A WHICH LOCAL HOSPITALS
ARE AT RISK OF REMAIN
OPERATIONAL IN THE EVENT OF A
MAJOR EARTHQUAKE AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NO FORMAL
PROCESS FOR THEM TO RECEIVE THIS
INFORMATION. IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS HAVE THIS INFORMATION
AT THEIR DISPOSAL SO THAT THEY
CAN CREATE CONTINGENCY PLANS IF
A HOSPITAL WOULD BECOME UNSAFE
AS A RESULT OF A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE AS A FORMER PAID CALL
FIREFIGHTER I CAN PERSONALLY
TELL YOU- THAT. EVERY SECOND
COUNTS WHEN THERE'S AN EMERGENCY
THERE IS NO MARGIN FOR ERROR
BECAUSE ERRORS COST LIVES. NO NO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THIS LEGISLATION
THIS BILL DOES NOT. DOES NOT A
SALARY TO THE TIMELINE TO MEET
THE TWENTY THIRTY STANDARD WHICH
AGAIN IS EXISTING STATE LAW.
THIS LEGISLATION IS JUST ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND REPORTING.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THIS
LEGISLATION BECOMES LAW
HOSPITALS HERE CALIFORNIA WILL
STILL NEED. TO MEET THIS TWENTY
THIRTY STANDARD A FOR THE MOST
PART WE ARE ALL VERY FORTUNATE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO EMERGENCY
MEDICAL CARE WHEN WE NEED. AND
CLEARLY CALIFORNIA HAS SOUGHT TO
ENSURE THAT OUR ACCESS TO
MEDICAL CARE WILL BE COMPROMISED
SHOULD UNPREDICTABLE DISASTER
OCCURS SUCH AS AN EARTHQUAKE.
PREPAREDNESS IS KEY THIS
LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE THAT WE
ARE PREPARED AND READY FOR THE
NEXT MAJOR EARTHQUAKE AND THAT
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS AND OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED. TO SAVE
AS MANY LIVES AS POSSIBLE WITH
THAT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS MISTER
RODRIGUEZ YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARISES CHAIR OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE AND PROUD
JOIN AUTHOR A. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WHICH WERE PROVIDED IN YOUR
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS FOR LOCAL
OFFICES OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES WHOSE
JURISDICTION THE HOSPITAL
BUILDINGS ARE LOCATED GIVEN THAT
CALIFORNIA IS DUE FOR A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE. THESE NOTICES
RICHARD LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HOSTILE STAFF AND THE PUBLIC ARE
ONE OF THE HOSPITALS COMPLIANCE
WITH THE TWENTY THIRTY SEISMIC
STANDARDS TO PLAN AND PREPARE
FOR WHEN THAT MAJOR EARTHQUAKE
HAPPENS FOR THIS REASON HOPE YOU
JOIN ME AND OTHERS AND
SUPPORTING A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU. THANK REYES
RODRIGUEZ SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. SADAMOTO
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT. CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY SIX KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS-EIGHTY THREE THROUGH EIGHTY FIVE
PASSED RETAINED. SAYS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SIX AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE CARPOOL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY NATALIE
THE EDUCATION FINANCE MISTER
MCCARTY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
THIS BILL WOULD ATTEMPT TO HELP
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS IN
CALIFORNIA. BY EXPANDING ACCESS
TO FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN LAST
YEAR'S IN THE BUDGET WE'VE
PROVIDED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR DISTRICTS FOR
FACILITIES TO HAVE MORE
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOMS. THIS
BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT EVERY
SCHOOL HAS AT LEAST ONE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM FULL
SCHOOL DAY NOT FULL DAY SO JUST
THINK ABOUT IT SOMETIMES WE HAVE
THESE PART TIME. PART DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS WOULD
START AT ELEVEN AM AND FINISH AT
TWO PM HOW'S THAT WORKING
PARENTS SUPPOSED TO GO TO WORK.
TRY TO GET A KINDERGARTEN ELEVEN
GO BACK TO WORK COME BACK IN TO
PICK UP THE KIDS GO BACK TO WORK
IT JUST DOESN'T WORK FOR WORKING
PARENTS OF THIS WAS WITH GOOD
FOR WORKING PARENTS. PLUS
EXPANDING INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES
FOR OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS AGAIN
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN OPTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ASK YOUR RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK GOODNESS MCCARTY.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
. WE ARE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN
OF FILE ITEMS. EIGHTY SEVEN.
THROUGH. NINETY TWO. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETY THREE AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY THREE BY MR MEDINA
AND THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA MAC LATER
APPOINTMENT MR MEDINA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I PRESENT
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE A
VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT
REDUCES THE TIME THAT LAID OFF
SEASONAL WORKERS HAVE TO RECEIVE
THEIR WAGES EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES AN EMPLOYER TO PAY LAID
OFF SEASONAL WORKERS IMMEDIATELY
AT THE TIME OF DISCHARGE YET IT
ALLOWS FOR A DELAY OF SEVENTY
TWO HOURS FARMWORKERS TYPICALLY
ARE NOT EMPLOYED. IN AGRICULTURE
YEAR ROUND AS MANY FARM JOBS ARE
SEASONAL IN MIGRATORY GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY OF EMPLOYMENT THIS
BILL MERELY SHORTENS THE TIME
FRAME OF PAYMENT OF FORTY EIGHT
HOURS THERE ARE NEGLIGIBLE COST
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AND COURT SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR MEDINA SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK LIBERAL. MEMBERS THIS
ARTICLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. THE CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS NINETY FOUR
NINETY FIVE PASSED RETAIN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NINETY SIX AB
TWENTY THREE OH ONE CORPORATION
SYMBOL TWENTY THREE OH ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AND OTHERS
NOT REALLY ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
DOCTOR WHAT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBER CURRENTLY BEER
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT ALLOW TO
SELF DISTRIBUTE TO. ADD TO THEIR
BEER TO RESTAURANTS THEY OWN
THIS CURRENT DYNAMIC CREATES AN
ODD AND UNNECESSARY OUTCOME WERE
BREWERY CAN BRING ITS BEER TO
ANY RESTAURANT IN TOWN. BUT THEY
OWN THE RESTAURANT NEXT DOOR
THEY MUST USE A DISTRIBUTOR WILL
FIRST TAKE THE BEER BACK TO A
WAREHOUSE OFTEN IN ANOTHER CITY
BEFORE BRINGING THE BEER BACK TO
THE RESTAURANT NEXT DOOR. THIS
RESULTS IN OBVIOUS
INEFFICIENCIES AS WELL AS
WASTEFUL TRANSPORTATION COSTS
AND GHG EMISSIONS AB TWENTY
THREE OH ONE WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW
BEER MANUFACTURERS TO SELF
DISTRIBUTE THEIR BEER TO
RESTAURANTS THEY OWN. WITHIN A
FIVE MILE RADIUS OF THE
MANUFACTURING SITE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEE
NO DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. THE CLUB THE WRONG. SORRY
BOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
VOTE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE AND
TELL YOU VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM. NINETY SEVEN.
AB TWENTY THREE OH SEVEN BY MR
BERMAN. ACCORDING ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE OH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS NOT CLINTON HOW CALLED
BEVERAGES MR BERMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AS
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERIES FIND
THEMSELVES COMPETING FOR
CONSUMER AWARENESS TASTING ROOMS
WHICH UTILIZED LICENSE. ARE
PRIME MEANS TO INCREASE BRAND
RECOGNITION IN THE CONSUMER
FOLLOWING AB TWENTY THREE OH
SEVEN WOULD ALLOW THE NUMBER OF
DUPLICATE LICENSES HELD BY A
BEER MANUFACTURER TO GROW FROM
SIX TO EIGHT. AND THE NUMBER OF
THOSE THAT CAN BE USED FOR
BONAFIDE EATING ESTABLISHMENTS
TO GROW FROM TWO TO FOUR THIS
INCREMENTAL INCREASE WILL BETTER
ENABLE OUR HOMEGROWN BREWERS TO
REMAIN COMPETITIVE RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT VOTE. THANK A MISPRINT
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IT IS OUT OF
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRABLE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NINETY EIGHT AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTEEN CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AND OTHERS NAPOLI IN
THE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. DR%
ARAMBULA EMAIL ME THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTEEN THAT MINIMIZES THE
CHANCE THAT AN INDIVIDUAL WILL
BE DEAD NAMES WHILE ATTENDING A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. BY ENSURING
THAT STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF
CAN DESIGNATE THEIR CHOSEN OR- A
FIRM NAMED AND PRONOUNS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. YEAH SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM THE GLOBAL- ALL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE ANTI VOTE.
N. FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY NINE. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY RIVER CALDERON AN ACT
RELATING TO INSURANCE MISTER
CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO WOULD ALLOW
FOR PERSONAL INSURERS THAT DO
NOT SHARE PERSONAL POLICY POLICY
HOLDER INFORMATION FOR MARKETING
PURPOSES TO SEND OUT THE PRIVACY
POLICY ONLY IF IT IS CHANGED.
THIS BILL SEEKING TO REMOVE A
REDUNDANCY IN EXISTING LAW TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF UNNECESSARY
PAPER WASTE GENERATED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. COCKERELL. SARAH ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A- CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
. THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED. AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY FOUR BY MISS POWER
K. HAND CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER POWER QUE HANAND
OTHER RESPECTFULLY THE CRIMES
THIS BARAKAT. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER CHAIR PRESENT AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY FOUR WHICH
INCREASES FINES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO EMPLOY MORE THAN TEN FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES AND GIVE JUDGES
DISCRETION TO REQUIRE THE
CONVICTED INDIVIDUAL TO PAY FOR
THE REMOVAL OF ILLEGAL DUMPING.
MOREOVER IT REQUIRES THE COURTS
TO NOTIFY THE APPLICABLES
LICENSING OR PERMITTING ENTITY
WHEN A PERSON HOLDS A LICENSE OR
PERMIT AND ILLEGALLY DUMPED IN
THE COURSE OF THEIR BUSINESS
ILLEGAL DUMPING IS A PLAGUE ON
OUR ENTIRE STATE AND A SERIOUS
OFFENSE THAT CONTRIBUTES TO THE
LOSS OF COMMUNITY PRIDE.
DECREASES PROPERTY VALUES AND
DISCOURAGES INVESTMENT IN
DEVELOPMENT IN ADDITION IT HAS
SERIOUSLY NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
OUR ENVIRONMENT. BY UPPING THE
FINES AND PROVIDING TOOLS FOR
THE COURTS TO HOLD VIOLATORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR COMMITTING THESE
ACTS WERE GOING TO DISINCENTIVE
EYES ILLEGAL DUMPING AND CREATE
PUBLIC KNOWLEDGE ON WHO NOT TO
WORK WITH REMOVING YOUR OWN
ITEMS. EVERY CALIFORNIAN
DESERVES THE RIGHT TO LIVE IN A
CLEAN GARBAGE FREE NEIGHBORHOOD
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FOUR HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS BURKE A HAVE. SEEN
NO DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLARK LIBERAL. MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE REMOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE DOES ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. PASSERINE TAMPA OUT OF
ONE ON ONE. MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE OH TWO AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS. FOR SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX WITH A
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON. MISTER CALDERON ON THE
IMMENSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AMENDMENTS TO AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX AT AN URGENCY CLAUSE
WHICH IS NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
MEDICAL PROVIDERS ARE PROTECTED
FROM HAVING THEIR LICENSE
REVOKED OR SUSPENDED. FOR
COORDINATING OR PROVIDING
ABORTIONS WITHIN CALIFORNIA OR
OUT OF STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND MR FLORA
FOR PROFESSOR WE WILL NOW SINCE
IT HAS A ROLL CALL VOTE. MR
FLOOR IS REQUESTING A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. VOTERS TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO
VOTE. MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING
MEANS THE THRESHOLD. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED WHICH TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS FIFTEEN ON THE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRETEND
BACK ON FILE. FILE ITEMS ONE OF
THREE. THROUGH ONE OH FIVE PASS
AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE OF SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY BY MR MEDINA. IN A
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY BY A SENIOR MEDINA
AND OTHERS AN ATHLETE'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO MAKING
APPROPRIATIONS FOR. MR MEDINA
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT A. B. TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY. AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
WOULD ELIMINATE THE CALIFORNIA
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CALIBRATE AND REINVEST THE FUNDS
IN VERY MUCH NEEDED COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS. AFTER SPENDING
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO LAUNCH CALLED
RIGHT COLLEGE THE SCHOOL REMAINS
UNCREDITED AND HAS FAILED TO
REACH ENROLLMENT GOALS AND OTHER
BENCHMARKS. THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM HAS BEEN ABLE TO BUILD ON
EXISTING ONLINE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND EXPAND VIRTUAL RESOURCES TO
HELP MEET THE VERY NEEDS OF THE
OVER TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS ATTENDING THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN. COMMUNITY COLLEGES
. THIS SESSION I HAVE MET WITH
THE EXECUTIVE TEAM AND CAL
BRIDE. AND I WILL ADMIT HAT
THEY HAVE EXPANDED THEIR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
UNIVERSITIES. AND HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO BUILD ON THEIR EXISTING
PROGRAMS BUT EVEN SO. THERE ARE
MANY QUESTIONS THAT REMAIN ROUND
THE TRUE FINANCIAL CLASS NEEDED
TO MAINTAIN THIS COLLEGE AND I'M
STILL CONCERNED BY THEIR LACK OF
DATA. ON JOB ON JOB PLACEMENT AB
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY WOULD
REAP DIRECT THE SUN'S CURRENTLY
INVESTED IN CALIBRATE AND IT
WOULD GO TO THE BASIC NEEDS
CENTERS STUDENT HOUSING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS IN
THE STATE FINANCIAL AID FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. THIS
BILL SHOULD BE FAMILIAR BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
THIS- FLOOR HAS TAKEN THIS UP-
AS A TEACHER A FEW YEARS BACK
WHEN THIS PROGRAM WAS FIRST
LAUNCHED I WAS VERY SKEPTICAL.
BECAUSE I DID NOT THINK THAT THE
WAY THEY DELIVERED AN
INSTRUCTION WAS GOING TO WORK.
BUT I'M JUST ONE TEACHER BUT NOW
THREE YEARS INTO THIS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SPENT I
THINK THAT MY SKEPTICISM WAS-
VERY WELL PLACED SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
AYE VOTE ON A. B. TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY. THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CARCLUB MARAL. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
EIGHT. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WHAT A PASS RETAIN A
FIREARMS ONE OH SEVEN ONE OH
WAIT WE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
ONE OR NINE PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEM ONE TEN. ONE ELEVEN AND ONE
TWELVE WE ARE NOW ON SENATE
THIRD READING. THIS IS. FILE ONE
THIRTEEN SB. NINE HUNDRED. ON
SENATE THIRD. SEPARATE SENATE
BILL NINE HUNDRED BYTES IN HER
TADO AND OTHERS AND I PUT IN THE
TRIBAL GAMING IN THE COMMUNITY
OF CEDAR OF TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. MS AGUIAR-CURRY
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SENATE
BILL NINE HUNDRED IS THE VEHICLE
TO RATIFY THE TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACTS. BETWEEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND TWO
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED CALIFORNIA
TRIBES. THE MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA
BAND OF POMO INDIANS AND THE
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA TALK TO YOU
. YOUR TRYM. THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA IS IN LAKE COUNTY IN
MY FOURTH DISTRICT THE TRIBE
OPERATES THE TWIN PINE CASINO
AND HOTEL WHICH IS ONLY THREE
HUNDRED FORTY NINE GAMING
DEVICES OVER THE TERM OF THE
EXISTING COMPACT THE MIDDLETOWN
TRIBE HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED. BY DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES INCLUDING THE VALLEY
FIRE TUBBS NORTH BAY FIRE IN THE
MIST MENDOCINO COMPLEX FIRE.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF MY DEAR
FRIEND IN THE TRIBAL CHAIRMAN
AND COUNTY SUPERVISOR JOSE AT
MOKE SIMON MIDDLETOWN HAS BECOME
A SAFE HAVEN NOT ONLY FOR ITS
MEMBERS BUT TO THE PEOPLE IN
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. THE
TRIBE OFFER SHELTER TO EVACUEES
RESP RESP FIVE FOR THE FIRST
RESPONDERS IMPROVISER EVENTS
CENTER FOR USE BUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. SANTA ROSA RAW
RANCHERIA TRIBE IS LOCATED IN
THE HEART OF SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
PROSSER FIVE MILES FROM THE
SOUTH OF THE MORE IN KINGS
COUNTY. THE TOUCHY HAVE BEEN
ALSO BEEN GOOD NEIGHBORS IN THE
REGION PROVIDING SCHOLARSHIP
ASSISTANCE JOB TRAINING AND
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAMS HEALTH
AND WELFARE WELFARE ASSISTANCE
AND OTHER SOCIAL SERVICES. THEIR
COMMITMENT OF THE NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO KING THAT KING
COUNTY. INTERGOVERNMENTAL
AGREEMENT WILL PROVIDE HALF THE
COST FOR MAINTENANCE OF A
CRITICAL REGIONAL FIRE STATION.
THE LANGUAGE IN THESE COMPLEXES
SUBSTANTIALLY THE SAME AS RECENT
COMPACTS AND REFLECTS THE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE
AGREEMENT FOR FEDERAL APPROVAL.
THE CONTACTS ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED IN BY THE RESPECTIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS OTHER
TRIBES AND HAVE NO OPPOSITION I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY MR SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKERS CHAIR THE
ASSEMBLY GEO COMMITTEE I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE HUNDRED. ON
MAY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
ASSEMBLY A GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE HELD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THESE
TWO TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACT.
WHEELER THESE COMPLEX FOR
REFLECT A MUTUAL COMMITMENT. TO
A RESPECTFUL GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP AS WELL
AS A PROMOTION. THE PROMOTION OF
A TRIBAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND SELF SUFFICIENCY. THESE TO
THESE NEW CONTACTS TO BUILD UPON
THE EXISTING CONTACTS SIGNED BY
THE TRIBES IN THE STATE IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE THESE
CONTACTS WILL FURTHER CREATE
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT THAT
PROMOTES TRIBAL SELF SUFFICIENCY
AND ALLOWS A CONTRIBUTIONS TO
OTHERS TRIBES COMMUNITIES AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IT WAS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
BUILT. THEY ASIDE TAG IS FOR
SALAS WHO ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU WAS SPEAKER ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE HUNDRED
MEMBERS A- THIS MEASURE SHOULD
BE VERY FAMILIAR TO EVERYONE
IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
PASSED LAST YEAR THAT EVERYBODY
VOTED FOR BUT I CAN'T SPEAK TO
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA WHICH IS
LOCATED. NEAR MORE CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT ARE THE
BIG GREAT COMMUNITY PARTNERS NOT
ONLY WITH THE COUNTY BUT EVEN
BUILDING LIKE A SENIOR CENTER
AND A COMMUNITY CENTER. FOR
EVERYONE THAT'S IN THE COMMUNITY
AND THEY OPEN THAT UP TO
EVERYONE AND I CAN JUST TELL YOU
THAT THEY'RE GOOD PARTNERS WITH
COUNTY AND- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK OF A SALAS
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLARK WELL
OVER THE ROLE. SACRAMENTO
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF IT IS OUT OF. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLES HOWEVER I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASS AND RETAIN I'M SORRY. I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IS A MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
EXIT CALENDAR SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN AND ACTUALLY TO
REAL ESTATE. THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS A QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT WE
HAVE ONE COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY. BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FIVE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY. WILL BE A PART OF
GERMAN IN ROOM. FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN. AND AT THIS TIME MEMBERS
MEMBERS OF THE QUORUM CALL IS IN
PLACE. AT THIS TIME MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MS REYES
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FROM
MY DESK MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. PLEASE GIVE IS REYES SOME
ROOM IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
FROM MY DESK MS REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE FOR YOU TO
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING A MEMBER
OF OUR CAR CAPITAL STAFF WHO'S
BEEN WITH US FOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS. HE WAS CHIEF CONSULTANT
FOR BANKING AND FINANCE. AND
MOST RECENTLY WAS MY CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR FIVE AND A HALF YEARS
HE'S BEEN A LEADER IN THE
CAPITAL AND IN HIS COMMUNITY.
WE'RE GOING TO MISS HIS WISDOM
AND HIS INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE
BUT WE WISH HIM THE BEST AS HE
VENTURES FORWARD. MARK FOR ROUTE.
YEAH.
THE.
MEMBERS WE CAN ENTERTAIN VOTE
CHANGES AT THIS TIME IF THE DESK
IS READY VOTE CHANGES IF THE
DESK IS READY. VOTE CHANGES AT
THIS TIME IS VALID THERE IS.
CALAVERAS AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX I DO NOT VOTING. CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALLADARES
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX- TO NOT
VOTING. MISS WALDRON. I FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN A. B. TWO FOUR SIX
SIX I TO NOT VOTING PRO CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SIX- INTO
NOT VOTING. AND MISTER RODRIGUEZ
. AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY. ALL
RIGHT TO NOT VOTING. BURKE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ODD TO NOT VOTING.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED GERMANS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS I'D ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR. OR TAKE YOUR
SEATS AT THIS TIME. WE ARE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THEY GIVE YOU RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION YOUR COLLEAGUES. THANK
YOU MEMBERS REMAINING MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
FOLLOWING MEMBER WAS GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK. ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY. MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. SPEAKER
AND- MEMBERS I'M ASKING YOU TO
JOIN. I WITH US IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA AS WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MIKE CORBETT. MIKE
CORBETT WAS A WORLD RENOWNED
MOUNTAIN CLIMBING SENSATION. HIS
NICKNAME WAS MR EL CAP AFTER ALL
CAPITAN MOUNTAIN IN YOSEMITE
WHICH SHE CLIMBED FIFTY SIX
TIMES. ONE VERY SPECIAL CLIMB IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE PUT MIKE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF CLIMBING. THIS
CLIMB WAS WITH HIS FRIEND MARK
WELLMAN WHO WAS PARAPLEGIC.
TOGETHER THEY INVENTED A NEW
PULLEY SYSTEM SO THAT MARK COULD
PULL HIMSELF UP THE SIDE OF THAT
MOUNTAIN. IT TOOK SEVEN THOUSAND
PULL UPS OVER EIGHT DAYS FOR
MARK TO MAKE IT UP EL CAPITAN.
AND THEY CLIMBED IT TOGETHER.
AND ON THE LAST STRETCH MIKE
CARRIED MARK ON HIS BACK TO THE
SUMMIT. THIS WAS THE FIRST
PARAPLEGIC CLIMB AVAIL CAP. A
COUPLE OF YEARS LATER THEY WOULD
CLIMB HALF DOME TOGETHER ANOTHER
FIRST FOR PARAPLEGIC. IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE MIKE HELPED
AN EIGHTY ONE YEAR OLD. CLIMB EL
CAP SETTING A RECORD FOR THE
OLDEST PERSON THE CLIMATE. AND
WHEN SIR EDMUND HILLARY THE
FIRST PERSON TO CLIMB MOUNT
EVEREST. CAME TO YOSEMITE HE
ASKED MIKE TO BE HIS TOUR GUIDE
. OBVIOUSLY MIKE WAS AN
INSPIRATION TO MILLIONS CLIMBERS
WHO WERE ABLE BODIED AND
CLIMBERS WHO NEEDED SOMEONE TO
PUT THEM ON THEIR BACK AND PULL
THEM UP TOGETHER. HE WAS A
HUMBLE MAN. ALWAYS TOLD PEOPLE
TO FOLLOW THEIR DREAMS EVEN
THOSE THAT SEEMED IMPOSSIBLE.
SADLY MY PASSED AWAY AT HIS HOME
IN A ONE EIGHT. ON MAY EIGHTH AT
THE AGE OF SIXTY EIGHT. WE WILL
MISS HIM BUT HE LEADS A LIFE
WELL LIVED AND A LEGACY OF CARE
HELP AND HOPE FOR THOSE WHO LOVE
TO CLIMB AND FOR THOSE CHALLENGE
TO MAKE THE CLIMB. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JENNIFER IS
DAUGHTER ELLIE HIS GRANDCHILDREN
AND HIS BELOVED ANIMALS MEMBERS
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF MIKE CORBETT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON.
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS. THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY MAY SEVENTEENTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY MAY EIGHTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY MAY
NINETEENTH THE FOUR SESSION IS
AT NINE AM ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MS BONTA
MOVES. AND MR COOLEY SECONDS
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MAY NINETEENTH AT
NINE AM WE ARE RETURNED.